you
beautiful their venue is the beautiful
beautiful venue it's great on it I'm
really excited
[Music]
I couldn't be happier to be the first
speaker because it means I get this over
with and I can just enjoy when I first
heard that the conference was happening
I was like okay I need to go he was
gonna be amazing and it's so far
completely held up to my expectations
it's their first time and I've been to a
lot of first time conferences and this
is one of the most well executed
conference of ever speaker selection is
great it's pretty good I can't wait for
next year I think about things that
we've been doing that's qualified how we
evolved our software over the years and
some lessons we learn about how to move
with big teams to work with big teams
integrate a lot of people together work
in the same codebase
and how our desktop application for
Spotify has evolved during the years
my name is flickering I work at quiz
shop and today I was talking about flow
it's a static type checker for
JavaScript developer Facebook and so far
this Congress has been amazing and the
local community really did a good job I
just talked about maze processing and
how you can use what's available in
browser already to do something that you
may think really complicated and you
have to use external library but it's
really once you understand a concept you
can all do it in browser
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it is my first time in Iceland I'm
really excited about it but this is so
different than it's like another level
of different nature and beauty I'm
really excited about it and I'm really
hoping for tomorrow we have this tree
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]